you and bill murray were always at each
other's throat it's true not always not
only but a lot of times right
what happened once what happened between
you and bill murray on that set of
saturday night live
uh yeah what happened i went to host
right in uh 1978 or something
okay bill had been my replacement when i
left right
and uh i didn't know him well but i knew
him
right very funny extremely yeah and a
tough kid from
chicago who probably thought i was from
uh you know
a very yeah and had never had a fight
right
unfortunately uh that's not true right
but um
here's what happened i went to the show
i uh
found out later from lauren that john
who i'd known for years john belushi
even before snl
uh had been quite kind of jealous about
my
rise to fame and maybe for good reason
the fact is that john was brilliant
and by by any real standard he should
have been the big star but
there there are things that happen you
know my name is said every week
nobody can spell his name right you know
it was legendarily known that belushi
was sort of the star in the group and
then you
danny was actually the the real what a
brilliant guy
he was the resident genius and all of a
sudden chevy did the weekend update
whatever the reason you charmed the
american public
you got for whatever reason you became
the face of saturday night live
okay so this a a little bit at john
enough so that uh as i found out later
um
john had uh said things to bill about me
when i'd been on the show that simply
hadn't occurred or existed
everybody knew that right um but i
didn't realize he had said these things
so it already worked bill up a little
bit right and i went in i was probably a
little full of myself after a year of
fame or whatever
i think that billy probably wanted to
knock me down a couple of rungs you know
and i think he wanted to take me on and
basically uh there was
words were said just before the show
in the makeup room and and he got it
he got me really pissed i finally went
to his dressing room uh just before the
show and said and opened the door and
said
uh if you say something like that again
i'm gonna yeah you know whatever
and and john was there they were both
sitting uh back in the car and i
realized in that instant it was john
because he gave me a look
it was
maybe a little guilty too because what
happened was bill bill
billy jumped up from the from this couch
they were sitting on lounging on
and charged me at the door and i
immediately got into a fight stance
which is
i boxed a lot and said you know all
right i didn't so i had no problem with
fights
um i was ready to level him and he was
probably ready to
scratch me up and uh at the same time
john
rushed to the door and together john's
like five
four seven build he's like six one right
i'm at like six three and a half at the
time right and
and john puts his hands in the door to
block it off and and
as i remember i might have thrown a
glancing punch off to his forehead
wow and billy i think might have hit him
in the back of the head so
john was the one yeah john broke it up
john broke his head up i mean i know
yeah basically and then also brian
doyle murray who's billy's older brother
came behind me and grabbed my arms
just stopped me oh great and um and he
was strong as hell
yeah he maybe he was very a short guy
but
uh these guys had obviously been in a
few rumbles so you're not close with
bill murray
even to this day well we've never been
close but we've been
very friendly we played golf together
he's oh you have oh yeah oh and i can't
play for crap
i don't like golf billy is a golf maven
right
he really knows you play because it's a
social thing
yeah yeah if someone invites you you'll
go yeah and i think we've made an effort
over the years to get to know each other
better and to put that stuff behind